all right k welcome back thank you for
having me back so it hasn't been that
long since we spoke it was like a month
or so mmm maybe two weeks only two weeks
yeah but how things been since I posted
your video actually they've been kind of
good and bad like the good part let's
start with the good because the good is
always the greatest part of it all so
the good part about it is I did what I
said I wanted to do I said I wanted to
be the parent that made it back and I
made it back I've currently been living
in the home with my children all three
of them you're a person yes in Carson I
was able to drive very far from skiros I
was able to set aside some differences
with family members that work things out
for my better to where I was able to get
back to my kids but it was a battle to
get there before I got there I actually
had to reach my breaking point went and
what I mean by that is I went through a
couple of obstacles that kind of slowed
me down and me trying to figure out if
I'm supposed to stay here or if I'm
supposed to go like this life is not
meant for you to get content and stuff
and stagnate it well I got stuck I got
comfortable and I couldn't get the
wake-up call that I needed so it took
something a little bit sort of more
severe for me to actually wake up the
guy that I spoke about in the first
interview I tried so hard to build with
this person right so this man brutally
attacked me when I say from 6:00 and
Sanford
this man attacked me where I was barely
able to escape with my life I was so in
fear everybody in the hotel or whatever
you want to call it the SRO I cried for
help no one came for help
these people actually sat by and watch
this man abused me and could not give a
lending hand because there are so in
fear or they feel like it's not their
business things like this are not right
this man stopped and forced me to walk
with him to the store on wall is that
wall no San Pedro in 7th Street which is
the green apple right inside this store
this man continued to brutally attack me
and all the people in the store had to
say was can you please leave the store
I'm begging this woman I had a seizure
the other day ma'am can you help me I'm
pregnant like this man is shocking me in
my hand he's doing all this stuff to me
and no one cared
I felt so bad because like is this
really what the world has come to where
we see people going through stuff and we
can't not stop just to blend the helping
hand so immediately I call my
mother-in-law which is my children's
grandmother and I explained the story to
her and she asked me she said are you
ready are you truly ready and at that
moment I know what she meant yes I'm
ready yes I'm ready
I will leave all of this stuff behind
just to have that moment with my
children barely escaping downtown with
my life I was just so excited to get
back to my kids that I didn't care that
I didn't have a pot to piss in I didn't
have a dollar to spend on anything
just being reunited with my babies made
everything worth my while I was so
excited and I really pray that whatever
it is that this guy is going through he
gets through it like
no one in this world should be left
alone and what do you do baby I'm gonna
continue to go through with my pregnancy
I'm going to take care of my child just
like I take care of the rest of my other
children and we're gonna grow from it
and that's all we can do I've reached my
downfall
I hit my rock bottom I got my wake-up
unfortunately a lot of people are not
blessed to get that wake-up call to
where they're like okay well I really
need to make this change now before
something bad happens I was able to and
with no hesitation I took it
Emory do you miss anything about the
past lifestyle that you had as soon you
given up drugs - no I don't miss getting
high the only thing I would say that I
miss is some of the good people that I
met down here that's it any time I hear
a figure out here schemer oh okay cuz
you're early it's good row for sure at
the time yeah but I met some beautiful
people here yeah like some that gave me
food when I don't have it close a place
to say all of that
like I felt good so if I'm gonna miss
anything it's just gonna be the people
that I met and what about working figure
out I'm not gonna miss any of that thing
no but it is something that I do want
people to understand about this because
they they look at these girls right in
the table if she can make all this money
you turn your job I figure oh yes which
is very different in Skid Row yeah it's
very different discoverable right so
they say she makes all they make all
this money right but if we're living
realistically $500 it's $80 a night to
stay in the low-budget motel 80 dollars
a night so if you do the math in times
that time 7:00 that $500 that they make
daily it's not really help and then
let's face it nine times out of ten half
the women out here that are working the
streets are working with the man
in this man don't give a crap about will
you sleep or will you stay
he's just care about all the money that
you bring in so that he can look a
certain type of way or he can like India
Rob yeah my and have the girls give rob
sack and it doesn't actually have to
mean that they're robbing you for your
money they may be robbing you for the
product and you never see the money so
it's like it's back stories to it and I
wish instead of people judging they
would actually take the time to actually
figure out who these women are and why
they do what they do or what led them to
do these things because nine times out
of ten at 18 years old you have this
suave man in your ear that's just giving
you all these sweet dreams as a child
because that's what you are at the age
of eighteen you don't know anything this
man tells you something that sounds so
good and yeah he has on this fancy
clothes it's jury oh you're gonna be out
naive enough to believe everything he's
going to tell you you don't know
anything they start off as babies and
get brainwashed into thinking that this
lifestyle is okay and it's not and I
really pray that somebody's daughter or
someone's son has mercy upon human
nature and decide that we gotta end it
we have to end it it's more things into
life do where we can fund our what do
you what we can fund our habits whether
it's clothes jury you know drugs stuff
like that air there's other ways to
support these habits and we don't know
these things because we're only given so
much to work with and it's sad but I'm
glad that my story ended up shedding
light because it's like a whole
it's a whole backside of it that a lot
of people really don't understand
oh she pays this man or she does this
some women actually get turned out what
a man where they're they don't have the
ability to leave this man has burn
bridges with your family he has taking
you out of state or whatever the
coincidence maybe it's not always that
the woman wants to do this it's deeper
than that and a lot of people like I
said categorize us as oh these working
women instead of figuring out what can I
do to help you what is it that has you
so tied to this lifestyle I've seen
several women die behind this literally
blocks away from where not even walks a
block away from where I used to stand
mass murderers like stuff like this is
real and you wouldn't want your daughter
to go through it so why would you sit
back and watch another one's daughter go
through it or someone's sister mother
it's painful and I really hope that one
day we all wake up and stop living in so
much hate and greed because that's what
the world has come to it's so much evil
so much hate so much green and it
doesn't have to be you remind me very
much of another girl that I interviewed
on my channel Kelly who
chose to walk away from this lucrative
lifestyle mm-hmm
ended up on Skid Row temporarily just
like you did just for a short time yeah
didn't like it and you know I helped her
with that situation and my viewers did a
donation campaign helped her
tremendously but it's a very remarkable
woman who has the strength and the the
mental strength to walk away from that
life and build another life from home
from the ground up and she got to
achieve a nice boost from that campaign
but you're doing it on your own yes and
then see the crazy thing about it is
some of us are not fortunate enough to
have that that mind frame yeah it takes
a lot of strength exactly and it's I
don't know I I was raised off it takes a
village to raise a child right right now
it's like where's the village
it's like we'd rather see somebody go
through something that we've been
through and watch them fall versus give
them the lesson that we until firm the
situation that we did it we went through
to help them from falling it's like it's
sad it's really sad oh well that's not
my family member or oh that has nothing
to do with me oh it's not my business
what life have we become to to where the
village is not helping anymore it's that
but I'm glad because I still have a
village to help me raise my children
yeah so you're you're living with her
now hmm you live with your mom I'm
living with my mother-in-law that's
great yes she opened her doors to me to
come and regain a part of life that I
was missing yeah which was my children
and you're doing all the right things
you know there's no reason to kick you
out you're not working the streets
you're not doing dirt I left everything
just for that moment to be with my kids
they wake up with my kids in the morning
or to hear them playing around I laugh
at all I hope you stay in this direction
and keep going doing I do plan to that's
great and I appreciate you allowing me
to share my story did
being able to unload all the stuff from
the last talk help you yes I did
it really did I'm sure somebody gave me
an eye-opener and like I said I've been
down here since I've been stagnated down
here or let me say since I was because
I'm no longer here since I was stagnated
here I was on a spiritual awakening so a
lot of things that I was sheltered from
I was allowed to see and I feel like he
gave me a second chance and I'm gonna do
any and everything possible to make sure
that I don't end up back here or on to
the roar yeah terrible they're both
terrible places different ways very
different ways but the outcome and the
ending have very much similarity yeah
right Johnson you get nothing out of it
fast money does not last long at all I
didn't touch thousands maybe even marry
as I just said in $100,000 cars like I
didn't bend with people where we didn't
establish stuff it doesn't last long for
a young woman to have the mindset to
walk away from the temptation of all
that is what makes Kelly's and your
story is so so remarkable people maybe
people don't realize how how what you
guys have done is is so unusual it
really is because I mean let's be honest
once you get bit by the hustle bug it's
kind of hard to walk away it's a good
drug right it is like an addiction cause
it's like you always know you're gonna
go and get some any fast weather
quickies mine exactly so you may be at
home oh my bills are due I don't know
what to do I do know what to do I do
know what I can do
it's not something that I want to do but
man it's all that I know right now I
need the money
and this is very hard for a person to
fall back into I'm proud of it thank you
I appreciate it okay thank you so much
for coming in again no problem thank you
for help
listening to my story
hmm how do you feel set up in back home
yeah charlie is a nice dad you're wrong
back
you like that mommy best papa
he's shy shy shy hey beautiful family
thank you so much thank you thanks for
coming thank you